this video is brought to you by liquid
IV more on them after the
reaction how's it going citizens of the
Reche Nation we are back with the Adam
Sandler voice because today we're going
to watch another classic from the Adam
sander archives it's time for Happy
Gilmore Aaron
a thanks for joining me once get how you
doing man you excited that's not Adam
zandler I feel like that Gilbert
godfried now Gilbert godfried here guys
we're going to fill in some more gaps in
my Adam Sandler viewing history once
again I did not grow up in an Adam
Sandler house so that's how this
happened we did Dan my boy Tera and I
did the water boy and now we're moving
on to Happy Gilmore leave a like for
going back and catching the classics
also subscribe and hit that notification
Bell Bell to get notified the next time
an Adam Sandler movie comes your way and
uh hey thanks to the folks of prepper
for helping us edit down these
highlights it is a task and we
appreciate them greatly for it as well
if you want to get the complete Happy
Gilmore experience play the whole 18
holes with us along with your own copy
that you'll sync up with come on over to
patreon.com theal rejects we also got a
bunch of other movies and shows over
there with reaction highlights and Wongs
included it is a blast my friends and uh
I think that'll do it for the
housekeeping Aaron are you ready I was
born ready for born for
[Music]
dler Ha Happy Gilmore my name is Happy
Gilmore oh wow ever since I was old
enough to skate I loved hockey okay
wasn't really the greatest skater though
that didn't stop my dad from teaching me
the secret of smacking the greatest Slap
Shot nice Cut nice cut my dad worshiped
hockey my mom didn't that's why she
moved to Egypt where there is not a
hockey rink within 1500 miles I like to
think that whoever recorded this home
video made sure to get the face hit in
two
angles it's important shot we need it
guys he always said that when I grew up
I could be anything I wanted to but I
never wanted to be anything but a hockey
player huh yeah my childhood was going
great but life is full of surprises Mark
mother's B in the music huh all
right whoa everybody be to hit in this
own movie after the funeral I was sent
to live with my grandma wow death by
hockey I was kind of nervous since I
really didn't know her that well but she
dressed
like the sweetest person in the world
what a grandma after my dad died I
developed kind of a short fuse that kid
right there just stole my party blower
and instead of asking for a back I felt
I had to Belt him in the head a bunch of
times with a hammer wow conflict
resolution most of the time I was quick
to say I was sorry a and give a massage
not bad High School I played Junior
Hockey and still hold two League records
I was the only guy to ever take off his
skate and try to stab somebody you know
that's that's a hockey game nobody will
forget I was a road worker X you do a
janitor yep excellent yes go for the
trifecta perfect gas station
attendant I was going to say downgrade
in size but upgrade and functional wow
has a whole
ass been working construction I'm a
pretty good shot with a nail gun uh one
day my boss Mr
Larsson waiting for that apparently he
also has a short fuse oh it's it's it's
um it's that guy oh dang anyways those
jobs weren't for me I was put on this
planet for one reason to play
hockey ouch don't you ever touch my P
wow how many times this guy tried out
anyway at least 10 times guys's got a
lot of intensity 11 times a charm as
they
say not a real strong skater though
ain't the best Puck Handler either hey
who leaves Puck handling out of this
talk about the way to handle my
pucks whoa damn is that go regulation
size or
what and number 43 the rest of you if
your number wasn't called better luck
next year no what about me I uh called
your number didn't I what no you didn't
well better luck next year wow what a
jerk definitely on team now I would love
if he comes out of this like you know
what I respect this we need Someone Like
You on the
team you had Moxy kid I went to high
school with a guy worked there so we got
extra meatball bye when are you getting
back never she looks so familiar also
she kind of look like drew beore a
little bit thank you to Subway for
sponsoring this movie got to eat fresh
hold on a second babe you're not going
for for good are you honey you're going
nowhere happy and you're taking me with
you ouch all you ever talk about about
is being a pro hockey player but you're
not any good ouch you know what you're a
lousy kindergarten teacher I've seen
those Finger Paintings you're bring home
and they
suck I'm sorry babe I didn't mean that I
I I think they're excellent finger paint
apologize to the kids for me as well I
am not spending the rest of my life with
a loser then get the hell out of my life
who needs you beat it leave me
alone I'm
sorry why don't you you just come back
upstairs honey I'll give you the old
Smoochy smoo oh oh no you know Happy's
going to make everything okay oh
[Applause]
Behave oh God get out of there kid kiss
you all over and over and
again go to
him
Terry yeah
I didn't expect it to happen
damn get it
lady yeah if this was That's my boy that
would have happened oh
100% hey you know why Ah that's my boy
that's my
boy well
done with the Fruit Loops yeah put that
stuff down that's my grandmother whoa
grandmother hasn't paid her taxes in
over a decade wow the dream I would have
but I didn't have any
money she's an old lady I mean look at
her she's
old I have no discretion here her stuff
is now our stuff well at least we got
the house right no you don't no I TR to
break it to you I have to take the house
too yeah my grandfather built this house
with his bare hands my my grandma's been
here over 60 years this is Gil more owes
the IRS
$270,000 and if you can't get the money
together in 90 days we're going to have
to sell the house to someone else yeah
me don't you yeah no no no I don't hate
you it's going to
be I just ate this
door my grandpa built with his bare
hands you're just the vehicle in which I
had to get my aggression out on the door
yeah hey look at this place silver Acres
Rest Home oh looks more like a country
club than a nursing home looks like a
frat house I'm telling you this place is
perfect you're going to make friends in
no time no get me out
of you you tell me how's that nice
girlfriend of yours oh she got hit by a
car she's dead in my
heart we're going to get your house back
in the meantime just stay here and and
and have some fun
oh B Stiller oh [__] I didn't know he
was in this that's hilarious and I'm
sure he's going to be a totally Savory
character he's very important to me okay
extra special character I'm talking
about
here I can take extra special care of
that young lady over there for nothing
okay I appreciate that kind of you but I
don't trust you I don't trust it could I
trouble you for a glass of warm milk you
could trouble me for a warm glass of
shut the hell up oh uhoh just getting
right to it check out the name tag
you're in my world now Grandma Hal L son
of
horel bit I can hit a ball past that
tree 20 bucks as you can how much you
want bet I can throw a football over the
mountains hit a volleyball over to Earth
finish up in there think of it as a way
to enjoy your grandma's possessions for
another half hour wait a minute is that
a Will Sasso no it's not yeah it's Will
Sasso is that Will Sasso yeah oh damn I
tell you what you hit a ball past my
ball and we'll go straight back to work
that's totally what Sala I'm not used to
not seeing him with hair yeah it's full
headed Hair W
Sasso oh
man
Vision oh what a lovely fall day that
house is like 400 yards away beginner's
luck 20 bucks says you can't do it again
bring it on oh bring it on also a good
movie great boys are going to pay for
that
oh that would have killed him
one more time double or nothing look on
will sao's
face oh ow you made a bet pay the
[Music]
man wowe dang all right Waterbury thanks
man tell your friends step right up F
see if you can out drive the amazing
golf ball uh Walker guy
that's great got it got to focus on your
back swing Carl withs and those knees
remember now it's all in the hips you're
doing great Creed
himself all in the hips is that what
Andrew said was it didn't he say all in
the hips all in the hips there you go
look it out Gordon shout out how often
do you play Never this my first time hey
you should play in the Waterberry open
tomorrow you're a damn Prodigy all right
I'll see you guys there
ouch he's going to play
God he's going to win yeah buddy shape
him mold him Carl Weathers hey mister
you got to wear a helmet don't worry
about
it what what the
hell oh God I love
it oh God I hurt a little but I'm all
right how many kids tried this 64 more
days till next year's hockey Tri outs I
got to tough it up who's your favorite
hockey team comment down below my friend
is a big Habs fan so you're a hockey
player huh yeah you going to give that
[__] up you're going to concentrate on
golf a real man's sport you have no idea
who I am dude no I don't back in 1965
Sports Illustrated said I was going to
be the next Arnold Palmer yeah what
happened wouldn't let me play on the pro
tour I forgot Arnold Palmer was a guy I
just think about the drink when I see it
what happened somebody else mixed
lemonade with tea first you know
alligator bit my hand oh my God I hooked
my ball in the rough down by the lake
damned alligator just popped up cut me
down in my Prime he got me oh my God
golf's no different from hockey requires
Talent self-d discipline golf requires
goofy pants and a fat ass you should
talk to my neighbor the accountant
probably a great golf or huge ass you J
you win the open tomorrow you're
automatically on the pro tour then who
knows
hand this fake an is killing me you can
see him holding it yeah that's the thing
it's like the length of his arm oh of
course of course don't worry about that
made of wood it's real
sturdy yeah it's okay it's okay they
probably have a mechanical one now you
got to get him a new hand I thought you
were Pro material Prime to make the big
bucks oh oh you now what kind of big
bucks exactly
$270,000 good morning sun isn't this
great blue skies fresh cut
gr my God
[Music]
no you repaired
it hey who's that Shooter McGavin
shooter
mavin that's where this comes from hi
I'm Virginia vennett director of public
relations for tour I'm working on a
cross promotional thing right now you
know what would be great if I get a
Pepsi a Pepsi Pepsi I'm a Pepsi girl in
a Pepsi World ladies and gentlemen
shooter
mavin I've heard so many people name him
as such and never known where it came
from laughed along like of course
shooter mcavin today's big winner will
be invited to join the pro tour and I
just want you to know although only one
of you gets to be my colleague all of
you are now my friend I believe that Yep
this guy seems great he seems very
genuine has Chris McDonald ever played
like a a Savory character I don't know
laferty Daniel and Gilmore happy it's a
good name happy Gil you one of those
clubs Punk wow Mr Gilmore I'm your caddy
oh I'm sorry about that no no no let me
carry these all right they're my
grandfathers are pretty old what should
I do then why you just watch me and make
sure I don't do anything stupid oh this
kid's probably a prodigy himself I can
see
that d ouchies with the ball there's no
goalie out there to block it remember
it's all in the hip hey it's all In come
on work with me now it's all it's all in
the hip yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
buddy
hips that's how we get ready for every
reaction oh yeah that's how we warm
ups
wowe wow it's like an inverted Evil Dead
shot yeah totally how do they get that
shot anyway I guess by helicopter at
this point it would have to be a
helicopter they never drones back then
yeah or they just had somebody throw a
camera yep that's the most plausible
option don't break the wrist and bring
that putter back just like you're
confusing me just let me put the ball in
a hole Yeah aam's razor man the simplest
answer is the best
one
uhoh this is the part you're going to
have to to refine my
friend you can do the drive but you got
to have the putts man don't want to be a
putts v time and I just couldn't get the
ball in the hole I wanted to but I just
couldn't do it oh yeah wow took a ass
shirt
off I'm going to start doing that to
people yeah you got do that
[Applause]
[Music]
whoop uh damn what the hell thing of
beauty just like curved in the air yeah
man he's bending It Like
Beckham or like Greg Norman comment
below who's your favorite golfer
hey the only one I know is Tiger Woods
yep and apparently H Palmer yeah and
Greg
Norman he just got a hole in one on a
par he's a publicist dream I mean a guy
who can drive the ball that far you know
what else could dra crowd a golfer with
an arm going out of his ass oh can we
get one I to see that he jelly you a
little Jelly Belly oh we in the '90s
this song is baked into my subconscious
pack it up pack it in let me begin I
came to win battle me that's a
s she's like Bart Simpson
H
crew climbing the
[Applause]
ranks was this the most used song in
this era I feel like this song was in
every movie oh yeah feel like it had to
be I always you know the colored golf
balls always seemed like such a cool
special thing to
me yes very good very good make this one
in four less shots you win the
tournament four shots just think of it
this other team pull it goalie all you
got to do is tap it in I can do that do
it do it like
pull oh no overcorrection but but good
Instinct all you got to do is just tap
it in just tap it
in just tap it in a little tappy tap tap
tap tap it tap but tap I'm telling
you that's
it happy
[Applause]
[Music]
Grandma super oh my
God he must had so much fun that kid oh
yeah congratulations I saw that hole in
one on a part four that's got to be some
kind of record huh oh sure sure I skate
off and tried to stab somebody I'm the
only guy who ever did that oh jeez
thought we were going to add some money
for this oh well cheer up you next week
in Portland The Winner Takes home
$216,000 that's almost
$270,000 this is just as much I need for
Grandma all right so no matter what I'm
going to get some money
yeah I'll see you next week then all
right bye byebye she's she's delightful
mhm this is my first trophy only problem
is that Goofy Golf guy on top maybe the
guy at the trophy store if you put a
little hockey guy on there who the hell
shut your trap trappy
Gilmore happy such a trappy stop being a
damn fool people would kill to be able
to hit the long ball like you you got an
advantage over any man that walks out on
the tea oh you're probably right but I
just can't wait I need money that's
spoken like a true [__] look just no
I work with you every day no no no no no
no I I got to I got to go I appreciate
everything tell him why tell him why
tell him the truth tell him the stakes
man best of luck kid best of luck it's
okay grief carga tell the return $200
per quilt yeah well this is handmade
quality [__] we're talking here we're
extending arts and crafts Time by four
hours today my fingers hurt well oh now
your back's going to hurt cuz you just
pull Landscaping Duty ouch dude Mr
Gilmore how's my grandma a she's super
we're just enjoying some arts and craft
time right now
she's in a prison happy I'm so glad to
get me out of here see you too Grandma
I've been thinking about you all the
time Grandma good news I made the
professional golfers tour that's lovely
dud you know what else is lovely if I
can figure out a way to beat those other
guys yeah I'm going to get the house
back I can't stand to live in this place
another minute what are you talking
about I thought you like it here well
the air conditioner's broken I'm getting
a little warm just let the kid fix it
for you uhoh got the little twisty
knobs
oh m m get this off of me oh my God uh
you know that Mista Mista lady I think I
yeah just killed her
sure well on your
way the road so far
[Music]
Sam killing people hunting things I mean
saving people hunting things the family
business Supernatural ER superal all
right I'm Happy Gilmore what's up yeah
happy Mark welcome to oh not even close
looks like Hoffman from saw no I can see
it but it's not it's a nice jacket yeah
it is isn't it it give you one if you
win the Tour Championship hey what's
that s of the biggest Tournament of the
Year oh really yeah why don't you join
us at 9:00 on the ninth green what
happens there that's a secret of the
pros yeah dress huh oh all right all
right they're going to paddle him like
it's some kind of frat hazing thank you
sir may I have
another
excellent oh
no oh drippy
Gilmore sing
Gilmore uh dampened Gilmore gallons of
Gilmore gallons of Gilmore public
relations lady you see shoot him mavin
around why I just need to beat the
living piss out of him sh sure ninth
green at nine trick huh it would appear
so now wouldn't it you're right he does
deserve a beating he's just threatened
by you he's worried you're going to
steal some of his Thunder that's nice of
you to say steal the Thunder hey my
girlfriend's dead you know she fell off
a cliff and died on impact oh my god get
some sleep G more tomorrow's a big day
you're right it is and you have some
unresolved trauma over your dead
girlfriend hello everybody we're going
to have a nice crowd here on this
Sensational April morning 22nd annual
AT&T invitation
Sensational includes a group of elite
golfers from around the world the
favorite has to be shooter maabin are
those dudes like actual sports
commentators I remember well we missed a
lot of those in the water
boy I don't know I don't watch
golf thanks man hey he here's my last
buck this is the last time I'm going to
tell you a come on he's just trying to
make some money leave him alone
a that was nice he's out here for the
people name Happy Gilmore oh the guy
with the long drive hey what's your
Caddy's name H you guys haven't given me
one yet well on the pro tour you provide
your own caddy a all right let me find
that kid real quick where that kid at
hey easy with those clubs are right
their
antiques hey hey Gary Potter great to
have you on the tour Gary Potter is it
always like this with the uh TV cameras
and and the people and stuff oh yeah a
lot of pressure got a harness in the
good energy block out the B sure it's
like a carousel you pay the quarter you
get on the horse it goes up and down
around circular circle with the
[Music]
music I think I understood I nope I nope
Happy Gilmore all right give me a
club he has socks in
him why is Carl Weathers not here you
know he didn't want him to go compete so
soon support
it God whoever's in the booth running
the sensor button is doing a great job
on
it you think you can get it that high
definitely I can hit the ball even
higher even
harder oh a quar for the boat man safe
passage across the river
sticks
[Music]
go this guy's gonna have a glow up by
the end of the movie why did he put a
quarter there I don't know it was like
an interestingly punctuated moment
unless it's like he was he was doing
some Superstition thing for luck or he
was really giving it to him without
giving it to
him there's a reason they call you shoa
[Music]
[Applause]
mg yeah
as most golfers
do you're acting like a damn
fool you need to join the tournament so
you can pay for a new hand go Grandma
Shooter McGavin is putting for the win
maybe it's just me but his crowd seems
unusually small for this type of moment
oh I think most people have found their
way over to Happy Gilmore he's been the
talk of the course today with his huge
dve in his amazingly bizarre behavior
happy the ball itself has its own
energy its natural environment is in the
hall so why don't you send him home send
him home bags are packed he's got his
airplane tickets bring him to the
airport send them up metaphors on this
guy be the pilot you know you are go
home there
ball gold D it why didn't you just go
home that's your home are you too good
for your home they say you just can't go
home you know
oh
Javelin wow you almost gored that guy
put out a press release concerning Happy
Gilmore being thrown off the tour I want
to see a draft by 6 p.m you're right but
you know but he's so passionate oh my
God I just got a call from the Dallas
open their phones have been ringing off
the hook with people who want to see
happy they just sold out he's chaos he
brings excitement to the game wait money
Prophet if he cleans up his act he can
stay if he doesn't it's your ass any
more of
this who mother and he's gone you
P what do you think of Happy Gilmore I
didn't get a chance to see him play I
was too busy
winning where's my check we'll be
mailing them out next week sir oh no no
I want mine now I don't have any checks
to give well that guy got one right give
me one of them big ones I I don't care
that's a commemorative check but I have
always wanted to get one that was quite
a show you put on today Gilmore you were
the talk of the tournament wow thanks a
lot you know you'd be something one of
those long drive contest I'll tell you
what I know what you're doing right now
and I don't like it so why don't you
just shut your trap before I put my foot
in it I've worked hard my whole life
paid my dues and now it's Shooter's turn
and Shooter's not about to let his rain
at the top be spoiled by some freak oh I
was on this tour for one reason money
but now I got a new reason kick your ass
I'd like to see you try yes oh my God
hey hey what is going on here huh oh I
was just um looking for the other half
of this bottle and uh oh there's some of
it right dark why don't you just put it
down yeah I
know you'll pay listen to what I say pay
I say bars I can make things out of clay
and lay by the bay I just may what do
you say I can do this all day hey you
going to get dinner or should I pay hey
not bad not bad
slay
okay uh uh spray you can have fun but
you've got to keep it within reason all
right I will work on what you call
behaving but I ain't going to act like a
stiff out there sportsmanlike conduct
Happy Gilmore makes his way to the tea
in the 72nd annual Cleveland Classic hey
Happy Gilmore Drive 400 yard hey hey
he's back it's that guy uh oh don't be
alarmed Mr Gilmore oh damn he still has
the nail in his head oh my God put the
helmet oh my God the nail comes out next
week well you can hardly even notice
it Jesu Chris what is that guy that
guy's a Cara how you take that helmet
off without taking the nail out that's
what I want to know I know
[Music]
[Applause]
right every time with the shots these
like moving swooping shots in on him
it's great he's taking the drives trying
to reach the Green from here shooter
that's not possible sir Happy Gilmore
accomplished that feet no more than an
hour ago good for happy Gil oh my
God I feel like the nails making him
more
eloquent yeah
buddy hey shooter have a you forgotten
your nine
[Music]
iron oh my
God what a
frame they had to square that shot up
they had to light that
shot I do admire even though half the
time they end up in like pervy rolles
Adam Sandler always be cting like like
old people yeah like older actors and
stuff yeah totally and in this movie his
grandma is like super sweet so
yeah hey not bad okay money money
[Applause]
money oh my that son of a
[__] give me the ball
alligator a well train alligator damn
you've got one eye
whoa
chubs you took his hand oh my God it's
the gator oh my God oh my God no
[Music]
way damn did he kill it freaking merked
an alligator my
God check check one two one two nice
little transition too check four okay
get that money man
get that money save your grandma's house
this man is destroying golf I saw two
big fat naked bikers in the woods off 17
having sex how am I supposed to chip
with that going on Doug you've got to
kick him off the tour he's not breaking
any rules and until he does but he's a
disgrace to the game yeah the sanctity
of
golf sorry shooter there's nothing I can
do yeah man got to let the kids have
their day like every dog Grandma I came
in ninth place I won 30
$5,000 so we'll get the house back as
long as I don't come in last place in
the next two tournaments we'll get the
money in time yeah you know we should go
on that date I've been pretty good
lately well what is this I hear about
you breaking a rake and throwing it into
the woods I didn't break it I was just
testing its
durability at least I didn't punch
anybody all right okay we'll go on a
date oh just as friends all right yeah
just as friends slow down friends yeah
okay it's play date get a little time
here for Happy Gilmore anything what
happened to this actress I don't
know you used to play Ice Hockey shut up
shut up oh my God power failure did you
set this up
no I thought we were going to be just
friends a friends listen to Endless Love
in the
dark we are love
she has an a shockness that is very
endearing yeah This song reminds me of
seventh grade This song reminds me of my
grandmother she took me to see this
movie I like got the biggest crush on
Brook Shield oh sure what movie well I'm
not going to tell you a true copile
would know Aaron where's Andrew like me
yeah where's Andrew he would know she's
stuck in a damn nursing home the IRS
repossessed her house that's why I
joined the tour and I'm pretty close to
getting her house back look don't tell
anybody about this I'm I'm kind of
embarrassed uh-oh I'll make you a bet do
you always carry a puck around what the
puck if you get that Puck and nothing
that over there I'll never bother you
again if you miss you got to give me a
big fat kiss and she played hockey as a
kid
a talk about your all time backfires
oh uh I see it Go
in okay okay now he's a Happy Gilmore
she got the moves man damn oh my
goodness
move are you doing happy I'm Bob Barker
wow what a honor nice to meet you did
you get all your pets pregnant
this is a proam happy each golfer is
playing with a celebrity hey you know
Nick BDO and I won this thing last year
and I'd like to win it again this year
all right I'll do my best talking to the
right man hey Gilmore Hey Joe FL you
suck yeah jackass no why don't you shut
the hell
up what a reaction pun that guy in the
face right now but I can't you know
because I'm getting trouble I bet you
got a lot of that on let's make a deal
it's the Price Is Right at uh-oh let's
play some golf okay
Joe flarity is hilarious
onv Bob bar
alive what the hell what the hell was
that all about it's just that uh you
know it's rainy and that guy and it just
it just
slipped come on man don't fail in front
of Bob Parker damn it you will not make
this putt you
[Music]
jackass nice shooting Soldier
who damn all the way that far down nice
and
easy and you need Carl Weathers damn
he's getting in his
head that guy's driving me crazy you
know what's driving me crazy you not
getting the ball in the hole don't push
me Bob now's not the time maybe it is
exactly the time you that happy GM more
anger
man
wowe this guy suck
damn oh he and Bob Barker are now dead
last Jesus there is no way that you
could have been as bad at hockey as you
are at golf
wow you like that old man you want a
piece of me I don't want a piece of you
I want the whole thing oh yeah let's
[Laughter]
go damn
damn
let's go Bob get it Bob get those
College boxing days back in
there wow
jeez
no the price is wrong
[__] oh my God oh my God no I need the
price is wrong [__] that's amazing this
is like a Family Guy fight I love this
or like they live now you've had enough
him waking up is hilarious [__]
[__] that's right bom yeah yeah get
those Jabs get him so I'll see you at
the next tournament right oh no that
won't be necessary this was on national
TV Gilmore's gone well look let's get
something to eat there's a Red Lobster
nearby my treat Oh I thought thought we
were going to be friends oh friends we
are I just oh Jesus okay well I'll be at
the Red Lobster in case you change your
mind shooter oh he's going to turn this
is not hockey Mr Gilmore no matter how
much you want it to be I know that and
I'm sorry there was some guy out there
giving me crap and it took every ounce
of my energy not to hit him so you
decided to headbut Bob Barker oh who won
that fight
anyway you'll be fine $25,000 and
suspended for one month suspended I got
a play kick him off the tour well the
board thinks that that might be extreme
considering the fact that our ratings
were the highest that we've ever
had my grandmother's house got
repossessed if I can't make some prize
money in the next tournament they they
could sell it to somebody else well
whoop you do get out wow consequences
man I don't want to hear it it's over my
grandmother's never going to see our
house again Subway eat fresh we're back
there has got to be another way to get
the $50,000 I failed okay let me just
sit here and enjoy the one thing that
makes me a little bit happy this fresh
delicious turkey filled cold cut
com help keep me strong can I have one
of those coming right up oh my God Jesus
Christ Subway sandwiches will drive away
your hunger was did they really put this
commercial on TV it's a joke ad but it's
also a real ad let's go get your house
back comment below gang what's your
favorite sandwich from Subway and spare
no details I want every veggie every
sauce put it in the comments
below what the hell hey what's going on
here oh did shooter by the house shooter
bought the house that's going to be so
messed up you said if we get the money
by today we could buy the house back
right you can buy the house back bidding
will start at 100,000
100 do I hear the 100 this is the
exciting oh Jesus
275 at 275 new B in the middle under
three three now at 3 350 down front and
at 375 oh no at 350,000 down front sold
gentleman with the white sweater yeah
shooter probably right yeah a he's the
worst Shooter's the
worst you lay another finger on me I
burn the house down and piss on the
ashes oh what do you want for a shoor
you off the tour quit and the house is
yours fine I quit oh no he doesn't happy
I need to talk to you oh yeah look I did
this so I could get Grandma's house back
now I can no regrets what do you think
grandma wants more to get her house back
or to see her grandson succeed uh not to
be in that nursing home maybe there's a
way she can have both four championships
next week right if I beat you I get the
house back you beat me I'll quit you're
going to beat me the golf oh you're on
you're in big trouble though pal I eat
pieces of [__] like you for breakfast
you eat pieces of [__] for
breakfast enjoy your dokos boy
[Music]
[Laughter]
Doos i f with those poopy
Loops
no or just regular raisin brand
cereal I was wrong you were right you're
the best I'm the worst let's go crispy
craps frosted shitty
weeds are you ready to get down to
business and do exactly what I tell you
to do believe me I'm ready then let's
get the work right
[__] not I'm breaking the hand oh my God
just buy a new one bro they've got to
have advanced line up six in in front
Okay six Ines ni
oh hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey he's laughing he's having a good
time you going to break those
teeth w ah it's rigged the game's rigged
ha that clown easy if you can't beat the
clown how you going to beat Sho mavin
it's going to hit it through the teeth
what's the
difference
yeah what the hell you're going to die
clown you think funny I don't hear you
laughing now enough what I can't do it
sure you can you just you just did
remember now this isn't hockey you don't
play play with raw emotion you can't
putt angry you have to clear your mind
of everything else stay focused is this
a real mini golf course
wow now how the hell am I going to do
that think of a place that's really
perfect your own happy place the place
you shot grown-ups
at happy place happy place Happy Happ
place
Happy my God it's your lady Jesus Christ
lady and ler the ultimate mantasy are
those both Michelob
Ultra grandma getting that money now how
do you feel better now put it's like the
opposite of the water
boy yeah
hey happy
place
got something really special for you
here thanks you see that that is the
same putter I used when I played
slightly modified of course to be like a
hockey stick all you got the spirit of a
hockey player in you happy so I figured
why
fight well I got something for you too
pal wasn't for you nonetheless would
have happened right so I wanted to show
my
appreciation that is
me yeah is it getting longer I feel like
that might be actually
true that's a joke I would put in a
movie oh yeah I got his
head did he kill
him no
[Music]
he damn he died that's
crazy
no oh my God I don't know how the hell
I'm going to play today just remember
everything that he taught
congratulations murderer his funeral and
gamer the same day you killed a golf
legend beat it m oh this is a memorial
you know what I'm going to do I'm going
to dedicate my performance at the Tour
Championship to chub's memory oh you
want to beat him beat him on the course
yeah I've got some very interesting
interior design ideas for Grandma's
house bedroom at the top of the stairs
yeah that was my room I think I'm
turning that into my trophy room oh
diab also I I think they had Carl
weather's Memorial like literally here
on the
green he's just over there
[Music]
right damn my God God
damn I wonder if a golf was ever hit it
like that it went like directly in like
a I feel like it it has to right the
most legendary uh here's a free
lesson can't learn that in the hockey R
but you can learn
this is it about to go in are you going
to get your wish oh he's closer though
after one day Shooter McGavin is in the
lead but the big surprise is Young Happy
Gilmore nipping at his heels and
trailing by only one
stroke and the third day Happy Gilmore
has taken the lead hey Donald it's great
to hear from you old cell phones I need
you here in the morning he loves
franchise restaurants happy lead the
pack oh happy is really on today some of
the best ball shots yeah in a movie A1
golf ball especially hard to get
mhm oh my God hit him with a car dude
how' you get a car on the on the field
what the hell what the actual
well you okay that was ridiculous
Che oh Jesus Christ what the
hell oh my God just keep off your feet
for a few days to hell with that I got
to finish up yeah baby but I can't
believe he's going to keep playing after
being hit by that
[Applause]
car oh no my that's the first time he's
failed to out drive Shooter McGavin well
well well Happy Gilmore is Human After
All Human After All death
punk if he's going to have any chance of
winning today he's got to get it done on
the
green oh come on now come on now he
wants to stay in this thing he has to
calm down and sink some putts he
actually had to like make it do that in
camera it was kind of impressive
mhm I wonder how many shots they had to
like redo cuz he actually
made go to a happy place hey different
lingerie
today is it a different beer as well oh
oh jeez
no oh
[__] oh oh
no no no no grandma no not Grandma not
[Music]
Grandma Cowboy
next no
dude these all count as
Strokes nice skip though yeah oh this
looks like the end for Happy Gilmore
shooter now has a commanding
lead
oh man always lost dark KN of the Soul
what are we going to do I don't know
what to say I stink I'm not going to win
that's all right sweet the house isn't
important it's just the house stop fraan
ising with the help Gilmore damn I just
want you to be happy darling just be
yourself yeah be happy happy grandma
wants me to be
happy oh my
get water all in that beer sh up happy
don't feel bad about me I got my hand
back
see and I'm definitely playing this
[Music]
piano I wonder if he actually did it
kind of sounds like it would be him
sounds like
him yeah
got his mojo back it ain't over yet
McGavin the way I see it we've only just
begun we've only just be we're back
[Applause]
[Music]
baby let's go get them deep focused long
lens shots y
y
heyy it's good
putt
putt putt in the butt putt putt in the
butt putt putt in the butt in the
[Laughter]
[Music]
butt let's do it in the putt okay let's
do it in the
putt
yeah nice nice and if shooter doesn't
get himself out of this current Funk
he's in he may yet again miss out on the
gold jacket don't Funk with my heart
[Music]
yeah that hole in one that hole one oh
nice shot it's okay you can still go
birdie you can go go birdie I know golf
[Applause]
terms excuse me I just got to get
through my ball is this boy going to
have the
ball oh
it struck my
foot choice of words the rule says play
it as it
lies o okay nice that's two that's far
shooter oh you can count and you can
count on me waiting for you and the
parking lot oh oh
boy what the doing bro got to get a
better view if he misses happy can t
put's way to
Victory
d uh yeah I was going to say Kil more
cons it will cap an amazing
comeback oh God I don't like this oh
Jesus I don't like
this dumb oh my God y are all dumb for
that and deserve that oh
great now I have a stinking Tower
blocking my ball we'll get this cleaned
up and you'll finish tomorrow right dog
no no he has to hit it now he has to
play the ball as it lies ouch Brady's
right take a shot Mr Gilmore that guy
the commissioner guy is familiar too hit
it around the tower sink your Putt and
we'll go to sudden
death yeah remember your training
remember earthquake remember what you
learned I'll just beat him now good luck
yeah go to the happy place go to the
mini golf chubs I know you're going to
help me with this one come on chub golf
golf Subway he fresh coming in clutch
great what do we
got
[Music]
wow my my
guy happy G wins the gold jacket yep you
did it man well
done I love you got his best gals in his
Hobo Jack oh my Jes he stole my
jacket
Gil
wow oh
Christ yes twirl it on he's trying to
put it on as he runs
yeah
oh my God great such a great shot oh my
God the pants on that
dude this guy like a wrestler I feel
like he is he has to
be we made it
team he said a whole word the whole
movie oh my God my man's just ready for
the high
seas he's on a boat oh Hoy here's the
chubs where ever he
is who is that oh my God Abraham
Lincoln nice
check who are you waving at happy nobody
Grandma let's go home just the Mount
Rushmore of great
spirits the
end all right
n was fun that was it was a fun fun and
you know what else is fun
gang leaving a five star rating if
you're listening to this on Apple or
Spotify that's one of the most fun
things you could do all right reject
Nation so today I want to share
something with you that has been a
wonderful addition to my health and
fitness journey that I discovered during
the holidays and that is liquid IVs
hydration multiplier I'm down to my very
last packet and I'm freaking out but
it's okay I got more in the ma now a lot
of you have been so kind to notice how
I've been working on my physical health
thank you for all the compliments and
one thing I learned is that proper
hydration is absolutely crucial
especially post-workout and pre- filming
after post-workout and my wife actually
introduced me to this product which is
perfect because we not only care about
quality but a good taste and quality
product whether it's after a sweaty
workout or just after you know a good
night out you know what I'm saying
efficient hydration and replenishing
electrolytes is key you just feel better
and it tastes fantastic I can't
emphasize that enough another thing that
I'm always on the lookout for too is
products that have zero sugar or zero
sugar added because that's one of my
main dietary restrictions for the week
and they of course got products that fit
that description that also taste good
too so yes thank you so much so liquid
IVs hydration multiplier is in summary
is they are non-GMO electrolyte drink
that delivers hydration into your
bloodstream faster and more efficient
than water alone sometimes drinking a
whole gallon is not always efficient but
in fact it can provide the same
hydration as drinking two to three
bottles of water I'm also big on
efficiency plus it's packed with 11
essential vitamins and we know vitamins
are good for the body it's vegan soy
free gluten- free and dairy free you can
customize the water amount to your taste
again perfect for post recovery
traveling or just having a big night out
you know what I mean noal so if you want
a booster support for the channel and
booster hydration game go to liquid
iv.com and use promo code Rejects at
checkout that's liquid i.com promo code
Rejects and remember liquid IV it's not
a real IV sure feels like
it so stay hydrated stay healthy and
let's keep crushing those health and
fitness goals together in the year 2024
wow wow peacock you don't even let us
enjoy the credits jeez that's another
one I've never seen oh my goodness oh
Ricky boobby Ricky Bobby let Greg know
rulas bobus well gang that was fun but
uh let's let's get down to Brass Tack
let's talk about this movie about this
Bang movie what you think man what you
think oh man oh man oh man I thought it
was a lot of fun it's a lot of fun to
get to see uh Adam Sandler and his prime
you know get to see this old uh this old
golf comedy about this this hockey
player
wants to not be a hockey player who
wants to be a hockey player who wants to
play has to play some D golf I got it
out got words do we do we watch the same
movie we watch the same movie he play
hockey bad at hockey play golf now win
at golf get Grandma house back you
should be the guy who writes all of the
synopsis on like you know when you pull
it up on the streamer and it's like oh
here's a little breakdown I should yep
I'm going to write all of them in
caveman as you've got the it's like if
the ones for Rick and Morty are like
that they're just like yo bro this
episode bro is what it is bro they do
some crazy stuff this time bro we got
some stuff going on yeah that's just all
the descriptions
are but yes oh yeah I thought I thought
it was a lot of fun you know it
was it was it was simple it was 90s you
know like I didn't understand like why
this is a classic movie it was really
funny like even though it came out in
what 96 the comedy still holds up well
for the most part and yeah just the the
constant gag with uh with Carl Weathers
and and the uh just there I don't know
there was a lot it was it was really
funny seeing uh him and his prime yeah
man that's that's my thoughts as I'm
processing and formulating what you
think of the movie no I agree I mean
because this is this uh I want to say we
watched uh that's my boy pretty recently
and then Tera and I also watched H uh uh
the Water Boy and this definitely
reminded me of the water boy in the
sense of like this seems like the sort
of Adam Sandler template for this era in
time it's like okay it's a vaguely sort
of sport related thing not to say they
were all that but certainly Adam Sandler
has like a vested interest in sports and
then yeah you have like Underdog with
quirky you know qualities for one reason
or another who's going to be mentored by
like a veteran actor in in h water boy
it's uh Henry Winkler here it's Carl
Weathers um and you know like there's a
family element of some kind he's you
know either up against or trying to play
for in some capacity relatable there are
a lot of like it's it's fun to see what
the tropes of the Proto Adam Sandler
movie are and uh and yeah just like this
I mean I associate Adam Sandler with a
certain amount of like uh you know crude
and um I don't know what you would call
it you know like insult esque humor
certainly
and this was sort of uh a little less uh
down that path exactly this was more
committed just sort of to the conceit of
what if hockey player but Golf and uh
and yeah like it's got all the
straightforward elements that you would
expect from a movie like this just yeah
with his Adam Sandler flavor and even
though again like I didn't grow up with
Adam Sandler in a huge way and I prefer
the kinds of roles where he is more
directly committed to a character like
this was nice uh because like water boy
is very much he's playing mannerisms and
there is like a full-on character there
whereas this is more like Adam Sandler
kind of being what I associate with his
Vibe and energy more in a general sense
um but I will say that that
while sometimes I'm not as uh drawn
towards the ones where I'm like oh Adam
s is just kind of like playing wise
cracking Adam Sandler he playing himself
in a sense just like a heightened
version of himself rather than playing
like a character yeah and that's and and
he's feels like he's kind of playing a
heightened version of himself here but I
think it it worked really nicely and I
yeah really enjoyed this and I like that
you know I
mean my for my personal taste I'm like
you know you you kept the sort of frat
boyishness to a minimum it's endearing
that he's playing for his grandma trying
to get the house back and stuff like
that and there are enough like extra you
know uh peripheral hij Jinks that are
happening but it's not as like insane as
it could be and I think that's kind of a
nice thing like this had the right
amount of focus because especially as
like comedies have grown and these
sports-based comedies like uh peacock is
throwing us tallad nights to watch right
after this and certainly that was sort
of like the decade later iteration of
the sports comedy with a whole different
you know kind of energy behind it but
something about those movies that I
didn't feel as much with this movie and
I like tallad andit certainly but you
know like that's from that Jud appau era
where you have you know more heavy uh
emphasis on improv and you have these
movies that'll be a bit more loose and a
little less tightly edited and here it
was like you can see these again sort of
Proto uh tropes of the Adam Sandler
movie like with Joe flare popping up in
a role that I assume Rob Schneider would
eventually be the kind of go-to person
to have you know the dude popping up out
of the woods not going you can do it
he's sabotaging him here but you know
like there there are fun little uh
nuggets and things and yeah like the way
his movies approach casting and the way
they approach like having the romantic
interest and even here like you know
it's it's obviously you can roll your
eyes at the fantasy of like oh she's in
lingerie out on the lawn with jugs of
beer but it's also like it's so silly
and it's obviously kind of knowing what
it is in that regard in in a way that
yeah at least feels self-aware and thus
you know picks up an extra kind of layer
of humorousness for me um so yeah you
know for what this was I I had quite a
quite a good time and you know being
again somebody who
wasn't you know you know I I there are
aspects of of Adam Sandler's flavor that
I am not always gravitated to and am
sometimes repelled by and this didn't
really have that which uh which was nice
you know which I didn't expect it to or
anything like that but yeah this uh it
was a lot of fun yeah yeah I also like
the the golf shots you know every time
the ball would go and like the the thing
they did with the camera thought that
was really cool uh yeah had some very
memorable moments like that Bob Barker
fight was hilarious proba the funest
thing in the movie for me uh just
everything with car Carl Weathers and
his hand was hilarious and yeah you know
like there there's the love interest
which is like obligatory for a movie
like this but like you know inexplicably
is just drawn to and likes him right and
it's just how unhinged he is like you
you get it because like oh this guy's a
breath of fresh air you know from the
status quo but also it is like you know
from the second they meet she's just
like drinking him in and and these these
you know such endearing smiles and
things like that and uh but you know I
guess here it it it makes a little more
sense because he's still a young buck a
young Buckaroo and uh and you know yeah
you get your some of your fun like
comedy cameos like you get Kevin nean
and you get Ben Stiller in a small part
which I was expecting shocked yeah I was
expecting maybe some kind of Greater
retribution on that character and that
was a thing that surprised me here was
like oh that the the winning the house
you know I just didn't expect them to
structure it the way that they did where
instead of it just being like ah we need
to win the final championship in time to
get the money it's you know having
Shooter McGavin step in and buy the
house you know raes the stakes of yeah
the third act I thought it was a good
way to in real time answer that question
of like okay well you know like you know
we got the money when they're doing the
auction I was like oh dang I didn't
expect this to start happening here uh
and then movie watch together where Adam
sandor needs to make some money for the
third act yeah no exactly like there is
like a formula to these things and it is
interesting to see how it warps and and
and yeah like movies like this where
part of the charm is you know roughly
who the troop is going to be and roughly
what the sensibility is going to be and
now it's just like what character is
going to emerge from this and what sport
or you know just Niche interest are they
going to make the focus to give this
thing the flavor uh so yeah like you
know and that does remind me of the the
the earlier phase in comedy of what
would later become you know like that
Jud Appel ear of like here's an anchor
man here's a a Talladega Knights here's
a semipro here's a Kicking and Screaming
you know just like yeah how can we sort
of modularly plug these talents into you
know various little bubbles of
culture this movie walk so those movies
could run sure oh yeah I mean this this
movie definitely laid down the
groundwork and then those movies
expanded on it um but yeah you know and
then you had uh Will Sasso in there DJ
Jackson is that guy's name I know I've
seen him and stuff um so yeah like a lot
of fun just yeah like little cameos and
and appearances and things like that and
I did appreciate how they peacock today
man move right move on move on watch
some else go go go um but yeah I like
too that they put like they committed to
the filming of the golf stuff you know
in both respect in ways that remind me
of the brief moments in life where I've
caught golf broadcast and those kinds of
shots of the ball and everything but
then also ramping that up with his
Unique Style and approach and the way
they shoot that with his sort of hockey
infused version of this of you know like
okay we're gonna go into ball vision and
every time he takes the big swing we're
going to do a S some sort of kinetic
shot you know uh yeah yeah I don't know
this was this was straightforward in in
a lot of ways it's it's sort of the
movie I was expecting but I yeah I
thought it was charming and I thought it
was well assembled well orchestrated for
for what it is you know for the most
part yeah nice solid little seven out of
10 for me I I dug it sure sure what did
you guys rate it leave your thoughts
down below and uh yeah thank you for
watching this video thank you for
commenting thank you for being along
with the journey and hey if you want to
see another Adam Sandler classic uh you
know I'm sure there are a few others
that we still haven't seen so leave
those down in the comments as well we
appreciate you very much and uh hey
we'll catch you next time much love be
[Music]
well